allez maman fais fais maman fais maman
Enzo et sa maman sont venus profiter des
activités organisées pour les fêtes par
la Bergerie Nationale de Rambouillet ici
ce sont les ateli créatif du Père
Noël vasy prends voilà tu colles on a
des ateliers du Père Noël où ils peuvent
créer plein de choses pour par rapport à
Noël plein de choses à mettre dans le
sapin donc on a des guirlandes on a des
cart des cartes de vœux à faire des
petites des petits anges avec des
paillettes et tout ça il peut faire ça
ici ils choisissent toutes les activités
qu'ils veulent
faire la crèche vivante est l'activité
phare qui séduit le plus les animaux de
la ferme y attendent les petites mains
dans une lumière tamisée et au pied du
sapin on avait la garde de notre petit
fils on voulait faire la surprise de
venir voir les
animaux c'est ici que les enfants
peuvent écrire leurs lettres au Père
Noël là aussi des indices découverts au
fur et à mesure de la visite permettent
d'avoir une petite récompense une
dégustation à l'Auberge du Père Noël jus
de pomme pain d'épic fruits sec et
chocolat pour réchauffer les petits
gourmands voici la clé pour trouver tous
les indices il y en avait un dans la
crèche euh un autre dans la basse
courour et un euh je m'en rappelle plus
trop pour les autres il faudra chercher
ces activités sont proposées jusqu'à
Noël date de la fermeture de la Bergerie
Nationale pour les vacances
d'hiver